[Music]
when matt ridley first heard the theory
that covid was actually cooked up in a
chinese laboratory
he dismissed it as being a conspiracy
theory on the lines of ufo landings and
elvis still being alive
but after a year looking into it he
thinks there's a lot more to this theory
perhaps
why joe biden has now instructed the
american intelligence services
to reopen their investigation into what
previously had seemed to be a donald
trump conspiracy madness he joins me now
matt thanks very much for your cover
piece
why did you start looking into this
because for a long time
nobody sensible thought this made sense
yeah it's a it's it's it's a really
interesting point i mean i
started out from the assumption that
mother nature is a better genetic
engineer than we are
and so it would be hard we'd be hard put
in a lab to to come up with something
this
this infectious this efficient this
lethal
um and then as i began to look into it i
started interviewing scientists for
an article in the wall street journal
about the origin of the virus and
the bats and the pangolins and all that
kind of stuff as it was emerging in the
spring of 2020.
uh and i i could you know it was clear
that it didn't quite add up and some of
them were
was saying well don't worry it will add
up but it it
you know the the market theory began to
collapse
and then in may 2020 two things happened
one a paper came out from a scientist
named alina chan and her colleagues
in boston
saying um this virus was very well
adapted to human cells from the very
beginning
that's unlike sars which took months to
evolve rapidly to become
a good at infecting people and the other
thing that
happened that same week was the head of
the chinese cdc
said we've tested all the animals in the
market and they're all negative now that
was very
quietly announced they didn't want that
news to be
a big splash but you put those two
together and you say well hang on
if it didn't come out the market and it
was well adapted to human beings from
the start
maybe it's been playing around in human
cells in the lab
and then one started looking into the uh
the labs
in wuhan and what they were doing and
finding that actually of all the cities
in the world
this is the one that has been studying
bat coronaviruses more than any other
laboratory on the entire planet and it
has been collecting
thousands of samples and the nearest
relative
which was collected by the scientists
from this lab was collected from
uh more than 1200 miles away by road
during one of seven collecting trips to
one particular mine shaft
and that in the months afterwards more
and more
attempts were made to find closely
related viruses
and none have been as close as that one
collected by the scientists and brought
to the laboratory
so for me it was very much a journey of
discovery but why
would a lab and wuhan be cultivating a
virus
for you say it was it was very well
prepared
to jump into human why would somebody do
that are we talking because one of the
conspiracy theories
is that china i suppose like russia
north korea
is developing biological weapons the
kind of virus you might
use to defeat your enemies is that what
we're talking about here because what
purpose would you have really
to be cultivating a virus that could
kill millions of people
well it's possible that there was a
secret bio weapons program we don't know
for sure
that there wasn't but it's pretty
unlikely this wouldn't make a good
weapon
and besides more importantly there is a
very open and obvious reason why they
were doing it
and they weren't at all secret about it
and that is in the wake of the sars
epidemic
there was a view that if scientists went
out and sampled
viruses in the in the wild they might be
able to avert the next pandemic
they might be able to identify
potentially emergent pathogens that were
likely to cause
major epidemics and uh
they they also wanted to track down the
origin of sars this started with
attracting tracking down the
the original source of sars and in that
they largely succeeded they found a
cave in in yemen where basically all the
ingredients of the sars virus were
present in some horseshoe bats
um and they reckoned that they'd solved
it but they continued to do this work
because they wanted to be able to say
look we've spotted the next virus that
is likely to cause a pandemic we've
found it we've understood it
we've even perhaps developed a vaccine
against it that was an explicit aim also
and a lot of this money was supported by
american taxpayer
funding the usaid the
american aid program um spent a fortune
on what it called the emerging pandemics
threats program
which uh particularly had a strand to it
called predict which was about exactly
this and a lot of that money found its
way to this chinese team
in collaboration with an american
foundation called the eco health
alliance
which was at its peak a couple of years
ago spending 17 million pounds of tax
sorry dollars of taxpayers money per
year
on sampling viruses in the world
bringing them into the laboratory
doing experiments with them and
trying to find out if you could make
them more infectious to human
cells by mixing and matching different
parts of their genomes
why would you try to make sure see it'd
be more infectious what's the rationale
behind that
well the rationale was if you take a bat
virus into the lab and you manage to
isolate
a live virus it doesn't like infecting
human cells
so you can't tell you can't work on it
you can't do
experiments with it so if you swap
uh its spike gene into
another genome of another virus
then you can tell how dangerous that
spike is
on its own that's the logic it's not
terribly good logic we now know because
the the risk is you're going to produce
a chimera virus that is more
dangerous and one of the things they
then did was infect humanized mice these
are
mice that have been genetically
engineered so that
instead of the mouse ace2 receptor
they've got the human ace2 receptor
and this is to to to be able to say
how dangerous is this virus to humans
we're going to try it in these mice
which are basically like little humans
um well you know
given how infectious this virus was if
they were doing it with this virus then
it's extremely likely that one of the
scientists or lab technicians
would have picked up an infection right
but surely
if you're doing research into that you
take all sorts of precautions if the
american government itself
is sending millions of american taxpayer
dollars onto this
they will be pretty sure but these will
be done in a controlled way i mean
nuclear energy is very dangerous but all
precautions are made to make sure it
doesn't seep out
surely the chinese would have that cover
the idea that you would might just
wander home
with a new pathogen capable of killing
millions i mean
surely precautions would have been taken
and the american authorities would have
to be confident that those precautions
were being taken otherwise they wouldn't
fund the program
in the first place well very
interestingly in 2018
the american embassy in beijing sent a
delegation to wuhan to look at the wuhan
institute of virology
specifically to look at its biosecurity
level four lab which is the highest
biosecurity level
that's the one which you do ebola
research in
um funny enough sars does not require
bsl for it requires bsl3
and they made several suggestions about
how this wasn't being
uh the safety and security procedures
were not good enough
and ought to be improved this was
china's only
and first biosecurity level 4 lab was in
wuhan at this institute
now as i say they were doing experiments
in bsl 3 on sars
itself but the bat
viruses the ones they were collecting in
the wild from bats which were
not very good infecting people most of
them
they were doing that at biosecurity
level two
and that was what the international
rules said by the way
now in bsl4 you're in a
spacesuit you're breathing through an
air tube uh you know there's
negative positive pressure in your suit
so that you can't you know if you
puncture it nothing comes
in um bsl three it's not quite like that
you are
at least breathing the air but uh you
are
totally enclosed in a suit and you're
working within a sealed cabinet which is
negative pressure
bsl 2 you're just wearing goggles
a mask and a lab coat that's it nothing
else
right so this sounds like a you paint a
picture
i guess a plausible picture of a sort of
chernobyl style disaster and you know
the history of
everything from the titanic sinking
onwards you know you the best laid
security plans of mice men and nuclear
scientists go aft
aglay but surely what you're missing
right now it still is just that it's a
theory you're all you're saying
effectively is it could have come from
the lab sure
nobody denies that but whether it did
come from a lab
the best evidence you've got is that we
do have not yet
identified the missing link that we
found with sars
one in other words they managed to get
to the original batcave they managed to
to connect the dots between animals and
human the first time around
nobody's managed to connect with dots
between animals and humans
this time around and that you're saying
well what about a lab leak
sure it's plausible but it's not
conclusive the chinese government still
described this as a absolutely crazy to
fan up racial discrimination
and xenophobia the when this was
mentioned then
back in april the washington post
described it as a conspiracy theory
the new york times that it was a fringe
theory the landsat has already published
a statement by
several scientists and condemning
conspiracy theory suggesting covert 19
does not
have a natural origin so surely a great
many people
including very esteemed scientists have
dismissed
this theory as bunken well that is
changing
um a year ago a great many scientists uh
as you say signed up to this view that
it was a
a conspiracy theory and a fringe idea
and
the problem was donald trump was in
favor of this idea and that made it
automatically
anathema to a lot of people but they
confused two things
one was the deliberate bioweapon
synthetic virus idea and the other was
handling viruses in the laboratory in an
accident
and frankly the latter has always been
much more plausible
you're seeing a lot of scientists now
climbing back off
over the fence to say actually we
realize that this is possible
um one of the signatories of that letter
in the lancet that you mentioned
has said i i actually i think it it it
needs to be investigated
one of the authors of a key paper called
the proximal origins of
sarsko v2 which was a very influential
paper in march last year
has now said he thinks it deserves to be
investigated so more and more scientists
have now changed their view and said yes
it does need to be investigated
but you are right that we have no direct
proof of a lab leak there's no record of
an incident and more importantly
there's no record of this particular
virus being experimented on
now you might the the wuhan institute of
virology says look if we'd had this
varus in the lab we'd have published it
well would you in in february last year
they
published the virus the genome of the
virus that was
closest related to this and they'd had
that since 2013.
so they don't publish things immediately
they had a database with 22 000
entries in it 15 000 of which were about
bat viruses
they were both data on where it was
collected but also genome sequences and
partial genome sequences
now that database 22 000 items went
offline on the 12th of september
2019 before the pandemic began
and they've come up with all sorts of
excuses why they won't share now
what was in it they say well there are
hacking attempts to it
well all the more reason to to show
legitimate
inquiries what's in that that database
um
also when they published that related
virus
that that's the closest relative of
sarsko v2
um in february last year
they disguised its origin changed its
name did not mention the fact that three
people had died
in the mine shaft where it was collected
and didn't say that they'd found eight
other similar viruses
at the same time now that is not the
behavior
of a group that thinks it's innocent
now it says it's innocent and you know
the chinese government says it couldn't
have come out
of of the lab but in that case be
transparent
open your books show us what you've got
and we will no doubt
be utterly convinced well that question
of innocence and i guess the question of
who done it
is the cover of this week's spectator
matt ridley's article
is there matthew thanks very much for
joining us on spectator tv
[Music]
you